corona nachgehakt was wir bisher wissen
unser thema heute gibt es alternativen
zu einem weiteren zu einem eventuell
sogar verschärften lockdown und dazu
begrüße ich professor detlef krüger
er war 27 jahre lang leiter der
virologie hier an der charité in berlin
also der vorgänger von christian drosten
herzlich willkommen bei corona
nachgehakt hallo
sie blicken mit jahrzehntelanger
erfahrung auf diese pandemie wie
beurteilen sie denn unsere situation da
einmal freue ich mich natürlich dass die
infektionszahlen runter gehen bei uns
aber auch in anderen europäischen
ländern
das ist eine große freude
dieses zweite problem ist natürlich und
das treibt uns ja alle um wie verhindert
man die ausbreitung die weitergabe des
virus und ich sage da immer man am
liebsten würde man alle menschen ein
ganzkörperkondom stecken und dann würde
man kein kein austausch von aerosolen
mehr haben und es wäre alles gelöst aber
so kann man natürlich nicht vorgehen in
einer gesellschaft und ich glaube die
zentrale frage ist was sind sie sinnvoll
maßnahme ich glaube das fragt das fragen
sie ja auch was sind die sinnvolle
maßnahmen und gibt es evidenzen für die
einzelnen maßnahmen die man ergreifen
kann
der derzeitige lockdown geht bis zum 14
februar was geben denn die zahlen her
können wir locken oder müssen wir gar
noch verschärfen
also für verschärfen bin ich nie ich
denke dass man jetzt das was man auch
der bevölkerung versprochen hat nämlich
einen schrittweisen ausstieg auch
wirklich umsetzen sollte man sollte vor
allem dort mit den gruppen anfangen die
eigentlich nach allem was wir wissen am
wenigsten die treiber der pandemie sind
nämlich und die gleichzeitig
auch eine gruppe sind die wenig lobby
haben die mich mit den kindern in den
schulen in den kitas schulen öffnen auch
wenn eventuell die inzidenz 50 noch gar
nicht erreicht ist also die 150 ist
natürlich so ein problem diese ein rein
künstlicher wird die ist ja irgendwann
mal politisch festgelegt worden
ich weiß nicht ob man die in einem
winterhalbjahr erreichen kann
ich bin persönlich auch nicht der
meinung dass nun diese infektionszahlen
die werden und täglich hören wo also die
die positiv getestet sind dann
aufgelistet sind das die wirklich das
entscheidende kriterium sind sondern das
entscheidende kriterium ist für mich die
belastung und die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems also wenn man in die
kliniken schaut in die intensivstation
schaut wie dort die mitarbeiter haben
ende ihrer kräfte arbeiten dann ist das
für mich das kriterium wenn das zu viel
wird muss man gegensteuern
sie haben ja offensichtlich eine etwas
kritischere haltung den lockt das
gegenüber wie sieht denn ihre bilanz
zwischen nutzen und kollateralschaden
eine slogans wie wir ihn jetzt gerade
herren aus dass das ist genau die
richtige fragen die sie stellen denn man
muss natürlich irgendwie eine
güterabwägung treffen wir wollen in
dieser gesellschaft möglichst wenig
schaden durch die pandemie haben
natürlich aber wir wollen natürlich auch
möglichst wenig schaden durch die maße
gegen die anti kroner maßnahmen haben
und dieses muss man abwägen das ist eine
schwierige sache
dazu braucht man auch viel mehr wissen
um die kollateralschäden das hätte man
meines erachtens auch schon während des
ersten aktes oder nach dem ersten lauf
besser bilanzieren können und auswerten
können ich hoffe das ist geschehen ist
weiß es nur nicht weil natürlich wir
oder ich zumindest nicht möchte dass die
kollateralschäden der den schäden
die schäden überwiegen die darüber nur
spekulieren ich befürchte es ja aber ich
kann ich man brauchte natürlich der
klare zahlen und ich glaube das ist das
entscheidende
wenn man politische entscheidung griff
dass man wirklich diese dinge
miteinander vergleicht auf der grundlage
solider daten jetzt gibt es ja kollegen
von ihnen virologen die fordern im
gegenteil noch viel weiter zu gehen die
sagen no corvette oder zero corvette
also lockdown bis wir in der nähe der
null zumindest was halten sie davon
na ja das ist natürlich erst mal völlig
korrekt dass es in der wissenschaft
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt
ich persönlich halte es für
unrealistisch das virus wird sich nicht
durch immer schärfere massnahmen
vorschreiben lassen wie es sich
verbreitet und gleichzeitig befürchte
ich natürlich noch mehr was wir
kollateralschäden nennen ich denke dass
es einen vernünftigen weg geben muss des
lebens mit dem virus
natürlich ist alle unsere hoffnung die
impfung aber es ist natürlich auch
möglich dass die im prinzip die gruppen
mehr durch solche das wird es gestatten
dass die gruppen mehr durch sagt werden
die erwiesenermaßen nicht oder nur
leicht erkrankt und wir unser
hauptaugenmerk auf den auf die
sogenannten wollen rebellengruppen
richten und die zu schützen
jetzt haben wir ja nach wie vor
erschreckend viele todesfälle fast 1000
pro tag gibt es denn überhaupt eine
sinnvolle eine realistische alternative
zu einem lockdown wwe derzeit
praktizieren
also die toten sind ja in der regel die
alten nicht ist der median der toten ist
das alter von 84 jahren also höher als
die durchschnittliche lebenserwartung
man muss sich also überlegen wie kann
ich dir die alten und die vor erkrankten
also das was wir wohl namen nennen
wie kann ich die gezielt schützen und
dann darüber gibt es eine große
diskussion es gibt kollegen die sagen ja
wir müssen hauptsächlich die bullen
arabien schützen und wir müssen sonst
die gesellschaft möglichst öffnen und es
gibt andere die sagen nein wir müssen
unbedingt alles weiter in erinnerung
halten
ich würde eher den lock down an den
stellen die ich nicht für so
entscheidend halte für das pandemie
geschehen oder bei uns im land das ist
ja ein epidemisch in panama heißt
weltweit die wir dort wurde ich lockern
und ich wurde gleichzeitig alles tun um
im prinzip die altenheime die
pflegeheime zu schützen oder nachsagen
ich will es mal so sagen nach dem
tübinger modell auch die nicht in heimen
lebenden alten durch besondere maßnahmen
zu schützen sind zum beispiel
taxigutscheine spezielle einkaufszeiten
in den supermärkten veraltete und testen
testen testen könnten können wir an
einer stelle ganz genau hinschauen die
hälfte der toten in manchen
bundesländern sogar drei viertel aller
todesfälle ereignen sich in altenheimen
kann man altenheime realistisch schützen
ohne den menschen einzusperren wie im
gefängnis er also das will ich natürlich
nicht die entsperren im gefängnis
sondern man braucht intelligente hygiene
vorschriften für das heim und die müssen
auch nicht von oben kommen sondern die
müssen auch im heim selbst erarbeitet
werden aufgrund der räumlichen
personellen gegebenheiten wenn ich
gleich mit dem personellen gegebenheiten
anfangen kann es ist die voraussetzung
für ein intelligentes hygiene regime
dass man genug personal lag die auch
zeit haben für diese dinge ist nützt
nichts da gehetztes personal was auch
vielleicht gar nicht qualifiziert ist
für diese dinge und keine zeit hat
einzusetzen sondern das muss eine lehre
sein sie werden wahrscheinlich gleich
sagen wollen naja das kann man jetzt im
moment ja nicht bessern
das muss aber eine lehre sein aus dieser
mystischen pandemie erfahrung für die
zukunft krankenpflege altenpflege
müssen besser honoriert werden müssen
besser anerkannt werden das ist also das
generelle was ich sagen weil die
kanzlerin die muss ja jetzt haben ja sie
muss jetzt handeln kann jetzt nicht
hunderttausende von altenpfleger zaubern
was kann man jetzt machen um jetzt alten
und pflegeheime zu schätzen
dennoch bestehe ich darauf für quasi für
das protokoll zu sagen dass die werte
der saison medizinischer und
pflegeberufe höher werden muss und nicht
nur mit worten sondern durch taten
konkret kann man natürlich ein
testsystem errichten das wenn man sehr
gute schnelltest hat die man quasi
besuchern und auch dem pflegepersonal
die ja auch das heim verlassen
immer wieder und auch den patienten
quasi dass man die testet dazu muss man
auch bauliche fragen nicht nur nicht nur
gute tests und das pflegepersonal was
das betreiben kann haben sondern man
muss auch bauliche voraussetzungen sehen
je nach heim wie das im einzelnen ist
dass man also weil sie schon eine
besucher schleuse hat dass man die leute
die besucher auch warten lassen kann bis
das testergebnis vorliegt dass man dann
ein intelligentes wegesystem hat dass
man gruppen bildet von patienten und
personal die einander die miteinander
nicht vermischt werden man kann eine
reihe von überlegungen anstellen wie man
das tun kann
lassen sie uns mal auf etwas anderes
blicken die kanzlerin und diverse
ministerpräsidenten sagen ja wir sehen
die sinkenden infektionszahlen aber
jetzt bedroht uns die britische die
südafrikanische mutation also können wir
wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht lockern
auch wenn die zahlen zurückgehen ist das
aus ihrer sicht plausibel
also mutationen sind erstmal etwas ganz
natürliches bei viren die viren
vermehren sich sie haben dabei auch bei
der vermehrung fehler in ihrem
wie das genetische material dann
zusammengesetzt wird und dadurch treten
immer mutationen auf und wenn wir ja
eigentlich der meinung alle der meinung
sind das ist ein tierisches virus ist
was zu menschen übergegangen ist wird
sich das virus auch an den menschen noch
weiter adaptieren
insofern ist also die mutation an sich
erst mal ganz was normales und kein
alarmsignal
die überlegung ist wie können sich die
mutation auswirken einmal kann dadurch
die viren übertragbar wäre
zweitens können sie gefügt virulenter
wären also eine höhere wertung scott
enzian beim infizierten haben und das
dritte ist wie weit kann dadurch auch
eine immunität durch impfstoffe
unterlaufen will und das wissen wir
jetzt also ist die übertragungsrate
höher sind die idee wären tödlicher also
die überall so etwas die pathogenität
oder virulenz tätlichkeit anbelangt so
gibt es dafür keine belastbaren daten
nach meiner erkenntnis dass 1 wo mehr
daten schon gesammelt sind weil auch
diese mutante schon länger bekanntes ist
bei der englischen mutante dass hier
durch bestimmte epidemiologischen
hochrechnung aber auch durch
untersuchungen erzählkultur nahegelegt
wurde dass das virus sich eventuell
etwas schneller vermehren kann
das ist muss man beobachten
ich sehe aber nicht dass heraus dass
daraus nun ein große die konsequenz sein
muss dass hier nun weitere noch
verschärfte maßnahmen ergriffen werden
müssen in diese mutanten gerade diese
sogenannte englische monte bereitet sich
gegenwärtig in großbritannien lettland
aus das wird ja mal als alarmsignal
gesehen
sie ist auch einzeln in deutschland
schon aber die das alarmsignal in
großbritannien irland weiß ich nicht ich
sehe ist ja immer ein bisschen
optimistischer fleisch
ich schaue auf die zahlen die
infektionszahlen des monats januar und
sehe dass sowohl in großbritannien als
auch in irland trotz ausbreitung dieser
mutante die zahlen massiv zurückgegangen
sind in irland so etwa auf einen sechser
london großbritannien und laufe des
monats bis jetzt anfang februar auf ein
drittel oder so und das stimmt mich sehr
optimistisch letztendlich sind wir aber
immer wieder an dem punkt die einzige
lösung für dieses problem besteht in den
impfstoffen wir haben inzwischen in der
eu schon drei zugelassene impfstoffe
halten sie das für realistisch zu sagen
bis im sommer schaffen wir es die masse
der bevölkerung zu impfen und haben
damit eine herdenimmunität erreicht ja
also das problem wird er sten und das
virus wird zu einem normalen
zirkulierenden virus werden wie viele
andere mit denen wir ja schon immer
leben wenn entweder die bevölkerung
durch immunisiert ist durch die
natürliche infektion oder durch die
impfung
die dass diese impfstoffe in so kurzer
zeit entwickelt wurden ist meines
erachtens ein riesenerfolg der
wissenschaft der firmen und auch alle
die diese firmen unterstützt haben
das ist noch nie so noch nie so schnell
gegangen dass ein wirksamer oder
wirksame mehrere wirksame impfstoffe
entwickelt worden sind
und ich denke dass neben den zwei oder
jetzt an drei zugelassenen impfstoffen
ja viele andere dazukommen werden es
sind wo ungefähr 250 derzeit in der
entwicklung einer pipeline quasi es wird
also sicherlich sogar vielleicht noch
wirksamere geben in zukunft wir wissen
ja auch noch relativ wenig über die die
dauer des schutzes wie lange hält also
die immunität an
wir wissen auch noch relativ wenig
darüber wenn die
im quasi geschützt sind gehen die
erkrankung wie weit sind können sie aber
dennoch in texas seien viele andere
andere dinge sind noch ungeklärt
auch wird das sicher impfstoffe geben
die besser quasi handhabbar sind dass
sie nicht tiefkühl ketten brauchen
sondern stabiler sind hier ist vieles im
fluss und ich habe die hoffnung darauf
auf diese entwicklung und ich kann hier
natürlich zu den sechs monaten überhaupt
nicht sagen weil wir sehen ja gerade wie
das ist mit der verteilung der
impfstoffe
das war corona nachgehakt heute mit
professor detlef kröger herzlichen dank
an sie und an sie zu hause vielen dank
für ihr interesse
bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]